[Music]
the declaration of the world's newest
republic was marked by celebrations
[Music]
with the music song and dance that
barbados is so well known for
but above all it was time for solemnity
prince charles arrived for the last time
as the representative of the queen
barbados head of state marking the end
of the british monarchy's ties with the
island once known as britain's caribbean
crown jewel
the creation of this republic
offers a new beginning
but it also marks a point
on a continuum
a milestone on the long road you have
not only traveled
but which you have built
then the british military flag was
lowered replaced by one that represents
only barbados which now has a new
president sandra mason we now turn our
vessels bow towards the new republic
we do this
so that we may seize the full substance
of our sovereignty
barbados was britain's first and most
important slave colony whose sugar
fields produced vast wealth for the
empire
it gained independence only 55 years ago
but retained the monarchy
barbados became one of the queen's 16
realms but for many the time had come to
cut the umbilical cord with the monarchy
duane a bayesian as barbadians call
themselves sells tiny salty fruit that
grows by the seaside a specialty here
he agrees with the change i feel to be a
positive that one of us is able to run
the country you know able to make some
decisions
but others like nineteen-year-old
kashana says that the decision to break
with the monarchy was imposed on them by
the prime minister without consultation
it wasn't even explained just one day
she said
it's republic and
that was it
the new president will have a largely
ceremonial role behind the prime
minister and barbados will remain a part
of the british commonwealth which queen
elizabeth heads
this former quaker plantation has been
the residence of the governor general
the queen's representative in barbados
for the last 55 years now it will be the
resident of this country's new president
making barbados the world's youngest
republic at least for now
as a farewell president of sorts the
prime minister awarded prince charles
the country's middle of freedom
and then announced another surprise the
nation's hero award to the country's
most famous citizen singer rihanna who
is also an ambassador for barbados
in practical terms not that much will
change
but for a great many here no longer
having to pay tribute to a monarchy that
brought their ancestors here from africa
in chains is a change that was long
overdue
newman al jazeera bridgetown barbados